and our shutout tonight for a small band
of investigative reporters who have had
an outsized impact on the officials
they've been covering for years in the
u.s. territory of Puerto Rico when more
than a hundred thousand people took to
the streets in San Juan Puerto Rico this
summer
demanding the ouster of the governor and
other local officials it was the direct
result of the work of a small team of
investigative reporters at Puerto Rico's
center for investigative journalism led
by executive director Carla Burnett we
were definitely we never expected
something like this would have would
happen we just thought that there were
so many things wrong with the governor
and his closest advisors and officials
that we thought that everybody had to
know how they were talking who they were
talking about and what was the tone that
they were using and it all came at an
almost 900-page transcript of an online
messaging a chat it's called between the
governor and his closest associates and
advisors documents turned over by a
confidential source the governor called
one rival a whore he wrote about another
we must liquidate him today one of the
governor's deputies brought about a
frequent critic of the governor I am
salivating to shoot her you you would
never expect something like that from a
government official about their own
political party a lies about the poor
people about women about LGBT community
about everyone you know you wouldn't
expect that just to say it in black and
white it was awful it must have been
amazing to see it right there in front
of you it was it was we were speechless
their story came as the people of Puerto
Rico were still trying to recover from
two devastating hurricanes and the snide
comments from the governor and his
cronies Minette
says proved to be a kind of tipping
point in the public outrage they just in
general they they talk in a very
disrespectful way about the victims and
I think God hurt many people you know
everybody here in Puerto Rico went
through a lot because of the hurricane a
former top aide of the governor wrote
about the growing problem with dead
bodies quote now that we are on the
subject don't we have some cadavers to
feed our crows within days of the
group's publication of the governor's
chats the crowds began to form on the
streets of San Juan leading to some
violent confrontations by police around
11:00 p.m. and that sent protesters
running first Governor Ricardo SLO said
he had no intention of stepping down
there are a hundred thousand people on
the streets politicians of all stripes
the President of the United States all
saying you need to go that this is
enough you've said no why not well
there's there's an important component
about rule of law and democracy and I
respect that process but the protest
continued fueled by the ongoing
reporting of the Center for
Investigative Journalism and then siento
que continúa against opposition after
hours of delay rocío finally said the
words these people had been waiting 12
days to hear I will be resigning
[Applause]
I have to say I was not surprised
everybody expected that to happen we
were expecting that to happen because he
had no other choice
but when it happened did you feel like
oh my goodness we caused this well you
know I don't see it as we caused this I
see it like us the people did their part
you know we do so many stories that
never have this kind of outcome so I
think it was it was the people's doing
what happened in the end the Center for
Investigative Journalism and his
reporters were applauded across the
island and by prominent journalists in
New York and Washington the praise is
appreciated Manette says but it creates
expectations for a lot more you know we
are very concerned about trying to catch
up with what people expect from us you
know we are also citizens we have
families we live here and of course we
are concerned about the outcomes of this
process but we feel that socially it has
been a great lesson for everyone in
Puerto Rico and also for other countries
and for other states and territories a
lesson about the power of the press yeah
definitely the power of the press and
the power of the people and the power of
the people I like how she told me we're
both citizens and journalists so our
shout out tonight to Puerto Rico center
for investigative journalism keep up the
good work down there that's our program
for tonight
thanks so much for joining us we'll see
you back here on the law and crime
Network next week good night